jetzt hat
hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video heute zusammen mit ja nix
genaues weiß erfolg bei der geburt und
so steht hier und immer noch
vorbereitung richtig und zwar gebäude
von und 14 arten von snapshot menschen
beziehungsweise snap schildern fünf
angibt auf meinen trainerjahren 5
aufseiten der nacht im videochat die
beschreibung geht auf seinem kanal oben
schaut euch das video an und wir
wünschen euch viel spaß mit euch gefällt
abonniere vergessen doch nach oben gehen
ihr wisst bescheid und da hat man nicht
oft fangen viel spaß hier
leute wir fangen an mit punkt nummer
eins oder snapshot menschen immer ein
teil ist sagt er der immer der der
fotografierte mal sein essen stehen auch
nicht verschieben
viel spaß guckt euch mal holtmann
chilligen machen zuerst mit zitaten aus
passenden filter drauf und ab meine
story nächster typ und zwar ist das der
hier denn er ist schrecklich der ist
nicht zufrieden mit sich selber und will
immer auf jedem bild richtig geil
aussehen weil er wahrscheinlich kennt
das mache ich aber auch manchmal dann
mach ich 20 bilder und die games hast
wohl egal aber wenn ich mich
fotografieren von joker fliegen mich und
fotografien mich dann für die leute ich
mich fotografiert habe richtig nein wir
machen weiter mit dem gehalt immer 20
bilder macht bisher 1 nimmt das scheiße
man kann es
jetzt da es geht schon wieder nicht
dicker meine passt jetzt noch einmal
kommen
das ist es das ist das kann ich denke
dass ich auf jeden fall richtig gut
drauf ausland doch auch schön
dieser punkt ist der kennt ihr den shops
von allen gemachten welt ihr werdet euch
so machst du so eine geile polen richtig
geil pose und die leute die aber dann
immer das gilt schon davon machen und
das dir ganz stolz dann erzählen und du
siehst doch ich rege mich immer darüber
auf wenn das leute sind die ich nicht
mag natürlich schrecklich
warum habe ich überhaupt nicht mag warum
hast du mich bei snapshot aber du magst
mit screenshot wieder geil vor allem
screenshot was du von wem kann ich da
noch alles möglich machen so geil opa
nachrichten
ich feiere das immer so ganz wenn du so
leuten screenshot machen kannst du weißt
du wenn du mit allen so dass machen
kannst ich finde es dann immer so so
leute was auf das nächste kennt wirklich
jeder das sind diese leute die
verbringen den ganzen tag im bett und
schießt fotos von yamaha immer entweder
das foto ist ganz schwarz weiß immer
noch dunkle oder die wie die fotografien
ihre beine oder die fotografen ihre
beine und davor es der fernseher cancel
ganzen tag mit schönem wetter kannst
bild voll mit weste und so auf den als
wären auch hier alles dunkel hätte ich
die rollen vor so immer noch drei
stunden im bett bleiben
bist du so leute nicht der typ das habt
ihr bestimmt auch alle schon mal gemacht
und zwar kennt ihr diese zu einer klasse
oder säuren euch ist langweilig
und ihr foto oder fehlt einfach
irgendjemanden und verunstaltet den
himmel da irgendwie kennt ihr bestimmt
das magst du hast es ist okay warum ist
und junge was mal zusammen penisse er
ist auch alles gut jetzt häufiger das
sagst du nicht so würde ich würde sagen
nicht ob es sich um das recht einmal hin
wo leute hier
ich würde sagen der bio ist leider
vorbei ich hoffe ihr hattet spaß beim
ansehen weil das der fall ist das auf
jeden fall noch nach oben kämpft jetzt
auf jeden fall in weiteren teil hier auf
seinem trabant abonniert ich habe mich
liebt denn ich bin eigentlich ganz
lieber auch wenn ich würde er nicht so
wie er sind jedoch mal angewendet schön
abchecken und ich würde sagen hier auf
der linken seite geht's weiter mit dem
video von uns beiden könnt ihr auch
immer trocken oder hier auf der rechten
seite mit meinem netz wieder paar
vorteile eines singles hast du dir auch
schon fünf mal angeguckt und vergesst
nicht so viel scheiße in der haut
einfach rein und wir samstag wieder